you're watching swipe hurry up on this
week's show
reusable robots what happens to these
machines when they retire blazing a
trail in London I meet the woman who
dreamed up a bike light that's taking
over the capital and Mario gets moving
in our games review hello and welcome to
swipe we're forever being told that one
day robots will take over our jobs but
what will happen to those automated
workers once they reach the end of their
life cycle well some people are already
finding unique and new uses for old
industrial robots as Chris has been
finding out meets Mimas it's an
industrial robot that has been
programmed to interact with people it
uses the gesture based software which
gives it the ability to respond to
humans sensors track and follow your
movement almost as if it's watching you
robots themselves traditionally are used
to do the same thing over and over again
so lots of repetitive tasks but the
actual hardware is incredibly flexible
if you change the end-effector
you can use the robot to do a number of
different applications one of the
obvious challenges is the safety aspect
if you have a 1,200 kilogram robot that
can move at 7 meters per second you
obviously have to treat that with
respect especially in this environment
where it's interacting with the public
there are a range of fail-safes that
step in should people go beyond the
enclosure and she would be able to shut
down or stop moving
dangers aside exhibitions like this one
give a glimpse into the potential
versatility of this kind of hardware and
it's not just art installations that are
using industrial robots for other things
programmers are coming up with a wide
range of applications for these machines
once they retire from the factory floor
students to the University in Australia
have taught this one to take apart
electronic waste it disassembles
dangerous materials rapidly and keeps
humans free from having to deal with
toxic hazards
and one company is combining 3d printing
technology with retired robots to create
a steel bridge in Amsterdam of course
many things went wrong a welding machine
exploded nozzles got stuck in the robot
got disoriented but then they became
long lines complex curves and double
curved oval troops it was like drawing
midair when we started out we had an old
retired robot well we are using it for
is more a generative task which means
everything we do is the robot is unique
its new piece there are many industrial
robots around many of them are in use
but also there's a lot of them are
unemployed right now and basically you
can give them a second Second Life in
what we are doing but not everyone is
convinced these kind of projects will
become mainstream very very expensive
machines very powerful and potentially
dangerous
it needs some skill to program them a
little while ago you needed a degree in
computer science and it's getting easier
but still you need to really know what
you're doing and sort of playing around
with them is not advisable at the moment
repurposing these machines might be
something of a niche activity but with
more and more industrial robots in
circulation it makes sense to put some
thought into what to do with them when
their career ends Chris Creegan Sky News
stay with us still the gum I'll be
finding out how one tech entrepreneur is
trying to save cyclist lives that's
coming right up after a roundup of this
week's tech news Yahoo announced that
more than a billion user accounts may
have been hacked in an attack dating
back to 2013 the Internet giant said
names phone numbers passwords and email
addresses may have been stolen there's a
warning Britain is not ready for 5g the
National Infrastructure Commission says
4G coverage in the UK is worse than in
Albania Britain is 54th in the global
rankings lagging behind the networks in
Romania and Peru Amazon says it's made
its first delivery by drone the online
retailer dropped off a TV streaming
stick and a bag of popcorn to the garden
of a customer in Cambridge it hopes to
and the trial in the coming months but
items can't weigh more than two point
seven kilos apple's bluetooth headphones
have gone on sale the airport's were
meant to come out in October but the
release was pushed back with the company
saying it needed a little more time
apple's been criticized for its decision
to remove the headphone jack on the
iphone 7 after seven years of research
in 2.3 million miles on the road
Google's driverless car tech might soon
be ready for the public the software
giant announced the launch of whammo
this week a standalone company that will
take care of the project still to come
we head back to stardew valley but first
four years ago a certain kind of bicycle
light launched on a crowdfunding site
the blaze laser light now it's being
built into every one of London's public
Cycle Hire bicycles I've been to meet
the lights inventor Emily Brook in her
new London office and I started by
asking her about the success of the past
four years yeah it's a university
project that's spun a little bit out of
control now we'll talk to us about it
just remind anyone who doesn't know what
the blaze laser light is so for
companies called blades and the first
product is the laser light which tackles
the most common cause of fatality for
cyclists which is been caught in the
blind spot or a vehicle in front of you
turning across a bike they can't see the
laser lights the front light it goes in
the handlebars it's got flash bright
bright brighter and then it also has a
laser and it projects the symbol of a
bike down onto the ground in front of
you you can see it on the wall there
that's squished as well as found the
ground it's the right perspective for
the driver and it's much bigger it's
about it's kind of a meter wide widths
in front of the cyclist why did you
think to get a a picture of a bike
anything to make you see when you're
otherwise hidden I realize the threats
in front of you you can see them but
they can't see you so if I myself
wishing I wish that van could consume if
I was right there he could see me Oh
protect myself there okay and then you
started off on a crowdfunding site on
Kickstarter and now you've got this big
contract with London City bikes how did
that come about
Serco who operate the bikes literally
went to the website one day gave the
call the office phone numbers they'd
love the innovation can you come in for
meeting and we've worked very hard for
the Kampala
year-and-a-half to develop a very
different product from this that's built
into the bike okay so it's built into
the front yeah so we actually replaced
the front of Lecter and in there now we
have the laser and how the light cancers
as soon as the bike is moving and in
darkness the laser comes on have you had
much criticism I guess in the early days
if you try to explain it to somebody
it's quite seen ooh it's quite difficult
to understand it's a light that project
image of a bike in front of the cyclist
out of the blind spot because people go
I'm not really sure that will work and
we're going to see that you see a
picture kind of oh yeah I get that I see
it real life and it immediately makes
sense how expensive is the line the
consumer one this one is 125 pounds and
the one in the bike is completely
different it hasn't got the kind of
aircraft grade aluminium casings and is
that quite expensive just for a bike
light it is it's a high end of a bike
light and one eights for you now are you
going to go beyond bicycles will always
be for cyclists bike sharing is a really
exciting industry it's growing there's
over a thousand bike shows schemes in
the world you know we want to be
technology partners for them and adding
our technology and other schemes all
around the world all right good luck
with it
Emily thanks for swimming - well thank
you very much now it's been a long time
coming but the world's most famous
Italian plumber is finally hitting
smartphones
here's Lucy with our games review Super
Mario run is a big deal it's one of the
few times that Mario is appearing on a
console that's not a Nintendo one he'll
be available to play on your smartphone
it's coming out on iOS first and then on
Android a bit later date basically it's
a run a game so Mario will run from from
the left to the right of your screen and
you tap to jump so you can play Mario
game with with one hand it seems pretty
straightforward very easy but honestly
it would be so addictive prickers but
all these coins to collect you've got to
reach the end of the level finally hit
that flagpole but you can also kind of
take on your friends and see what their
high schools are and try to beat them so
I'm super excited for this one I mean
they had it as an exclusive thing that
you could play in the Apple stores but
now it's finally coming out
you might know the term Space Hulk from
the Warhammer 40k universe or the fact
that it's a board game
so Space Hulk Deathwing is now actually
a first-person shooter game kind of
reminiscent of left4dead where you and
three others team up to basically take
out some alien scum Carly I need a few
minutes so a Space Hulk in the law is a
kind of debris field filled with wrecked
ships and asteroids and that kind of
thing so you play as a definite
librarian like a military tactician you
take your space hole you take your space
terminators that's actually what they're
called which is awesome I basically just
go around I'm eating and clearing those
aliens so it's coming out this week on
PC and early next year for consoles if
you and your friends like to get
together and play some games Space Hulk
is the one stardew valley is a farming
simulator but before I lose you it's
kind of it's possibly the most relaxing
game ever made so in stodgy Valley the
main character you do what basically
anyone who works in a big city wants to
secretly do which is kind of pack it all
in and move to the countryside so you
take over your grandfather's old farm in
stardew valley and you have to basically
work from you know this overgrown mess
and make your own farm live off the land
you have to plant your own crops you can
real livestock you can craft things and
sell them you can even get married which
is quite it's basically if you've ever
played like a Harvest Moon game you'll
know exactly the kind of thing or even
if you've been interested in Minecraft
it's the same kind of very relaxing
methodical game player that you can just
sort of stick on and chill for a couple
of hours and so it came out earlier this
year on PC and it wow the critics and
the fans check out its steam rating that
is a very popular game
well that's it for this week but if you
liked watching swype take a look at a
few more of our episodes in our YouTube
playlist just type in Skype you swipe
and stay up to date with all the latest
tech stories throughout the week on sky
news on mobile tablet catch up sky cute
and snapchat we're all over the place
we'll be back next week with a Christmas
special hope you can join us then
bye-bye
[Music]